[Musik]
die heute um 14 uhr mit einer aktuellen
zusammenfassung aller ereignisse
es ist krieg in europa putins krieg wie
bundeskanzler scholz sagte weltweit ist
die russische attacke auf die ukraine
scharf verurteilt worden das land wird
seit dem frühen morgen an mehreren
fronten angegriffen auch die hauptstadt
russische verbände versuchen zur stunde
in die region rund um kiew einzudringen
es soll bereits dutzende todesopfer
geben soldaten und zivilisten
schwere explosionen in der ukrainischen
stadt nico friedhofs die russische armee
bombardiert stellungen in der ukraine
auch der flughafen von mario pohl wird
getroffen es gibt angriffe auf mehrere
städte im ganzen land nach ukrainischen
angaben kamen dabei dutzende menschen
ums leben diese bilder sollen russische
militärfahrzeuge zeigen die über die
krim in der ukraine eindringen im moment
ist unklar wie weit putins truppen
vordringen werden der angriffsbefehl kam
in der nacht
ich habe die entscheidung für eine
militär operation getroffen um menschen
zu schützen die seit acht jahren einem
völkermord durch das regime in kiew
ausgesetzt waren bis zum ende streben
wir eine entmilitarisierung der ukraine
wer auch immer versucht uns zu stoppen
oder unser land bedroht der sollte
wissen dass russlands antwort schnell
sein wird und konsequenzen hat solche
die es in der geschichte so noch nie gab
wir sind zu allem bereit
die russische armee greift die ukraine
aus der luft an und mit bodentruppen
hier trifft es einen weiteren flughafen
im westen des landes auch die hauptstadt
wurde bombardiert inzwischen gibt es
meldungen dass russische truppen
unmittelbar vor kiew stehen sollen der
ukrainische präsident hat das
kriegsrecht verhängt
wir sind dabei waffen auszuhändigen
jeder der unser land verteidigen will
und kann bekommt eine waffe auch
zivilisten die zukunft der ukraine hängt
von jedem einzelnen ab
die nato will nicht militärisch
eingreifen weil die ukraine kein nato
mitglied ist sollte aber ein nato land
angegriffen werden dann würde das
militärbündnis wohl intervenieren
und wir schauen jetzt in die west
ukraine genauer gesagt an die grenze zu
polen nach lemberg dort sind derzeit
einige diplomaten aus westlichen ländern
stationiert aus sicherheitsgründen heißt
es die lage in der hauptstadt kiew zu
unberechenbaren und in lemberg steht
unser reporter sebastian sebastian wie
ist die lage von dort aus zu beurteilen
ja es ist überall zu spüren dass die
lage dramatisch ist jeder hier ist sich
klar dass krieg herrscht und zwar im
ganzen land das hat auch gerade nochmal
der ukrainische aussenminister die
metropole war gesagt das ist kein
lokaler angriff nur im donbass sondern
das ist ein angriff auf breiter front
und dementsprechend stellen sich hier
auch alle einen der präsident hat das
kriegsrecht verhängt und an berater soll
gesagt haben dass ein dekret beim
ukrainischen parlament der rhader liegt
das zur generalmobilmachung aufruft also
dramatische lage im land und wie
reagiert die zivilbevölkerung auf die
situation
ja ich war vorher hier in der stadt
unterwegs und vor jeder bank an der ich
vorbeigekommen bin sind lange schlangen
gewesen also die leute decken sich hier
mit bargeld ein auch vor bäckereien sind
lange schlangen die leute holen sich
brot machen sich auf das schlimmste
gefasst wir hören von unseren reportern
die im land unterwegs sind dass es lange
staus auf den ausfallstraßen von kiew
geben soll fünf millionen sollen
unterwegs oder könnten sich auf den weg
machen diese zahl wird gemeldet
bestätigen lässt sich das natürlich noch
nicht also das könnte auch hier in
gewisse oder lemberg auf die stadt
zukommen hier im westen der ukraine nur
70 kilometer entfernt von der polnischen
grenze sebastian ihm ganz herzlichen
dank wir blicken jetzt nach russland in
moskau so scheint es business as usual
das öffentliche leben verläuft scheinbar
ganz normal und der russische präsident
empfängt inmitten dieses krieges
pakistans premierminister kan die beiden
so heißt es treffen sich zu einem
meinungsaustausch
sprechen auch über die zusammenarbeit im
energiebereich
putin dirigiert das geschehen lässt aber
andere sprechen frage an unsere
reporterin anna weiß in moskau was ist
denn aktuell aus dem kreml zu hören
ja die letzte nachricht kam von dimitri
peskow auf das ist der kreml sprecher
der sagte der russland gehe es nicht um
eine besetzung der ukraine das ziel sei
die komplette
demilitarisierung und die ratifizierung
und ich die tiere das bedeutet die
neutralisierung und des militär
potenzial das in letzter zeit auch dank
der energischen aktivität des auslands
erheblich gewachsen ist damit im
internet für durch den westen und
amerika auch wolodin der sprecher der
staatsduma sagte diese aktion ziele
eigentlich auf den frieden ab man wolle
das brudervolk in der ukraine befreien
aus den fängen der nazis die gelenke
werden von dem westen und etwas bizarr
anmuten dass inmitten dieser kommentare
sich auch der belarussische präsident
lukaschenka einmischt und anbietet in
minsk friedensgespräche zu führen
zwischen der ukraine und russland
denn dieser konflikt seien zu stoppen
und die einzige bedingung sei dass die
ukraine komplett demilitarisiert werde
und eben abrückt von da einer nato
mitgliedschaft oder dem wunsch nach
einer nato-mitgliedschaft anna vielen
dank nach moskau für den moment in
deutschland hat die politik den
russischen einmarsch in die ukraine mit
drastischen worten verurteilt es handele
sich um einen eklatanten bruch des
völkerrechts so kanzler scholz aus
ministerin baerbock sagte heute sei man
in einer anderen welt aufgewacht und
bundestagspräsidentin bars spricht von
einem schwarzen tag in der geschichte
europas und der ganzen welt
um 10 uhr hat der kanzler das
sicherheitskabinett zusammengerufen
krisensitzung mit den ministern und
ministerin für innere und äußere
sicherheit
anschließend verurteilt scholz putins
angriff auf die ukraine scharf er
verletzt die souveränität und die
grenzen der ukraine
er gefährdet das leben von unzähligen
unschuldigen in der ukraine dem bruder
volk russlands
herzlich stellt er damit auch die
friedensordnung unseres kontinents in
fragen für all das
gibt es keine rechtfertigung das ist
putins krieg noch heute würden massive
sanktionen auf den weg gebracht so
scholz die nato hat ihre
verteidigungspläne aktiviert die
deutsche verteidigungsministerin mahnt
zur geschlossenheit putin tritt
völkerrecht mit füßen und nimmt
unfassbares leid in auch in kauf um
seine großmacht fantasien zu befriedigen
das muss ein ende haben wir müssen
geschlossen stehen in der nato in der eu
und jetzt muss es ganz schnell wirksame
konsequente sanktionen geben klar wird
spätestens heute die diplomatischen
bemühungen der letzten wochen waren
vergeblich vizekanzler harbeck zeigt
sich selbstkritisch rückblickend muss
man sagen wenn man sich die schriften
von putin aus dem letzten sommer
anschaut wenn man die wortbeiträge
zusammen schneidet das der westen europa
deutschland zu naiv die opposition
verurteilt heute geschlossenen russlands
angriff der cdu-chef sichert der
regierung unterstützung zu wir sollten
hier auch innenpolitisch sehr klar und
deutlich sagen wir werden jede maßnahme
unterstützen auch als union die darauf
ausgerichtet ist dass nato territorium
vor weiteren übergriffen
russland zu schützen wenn notwendig auch
militärisch für sonntag hat der kanzler
eine sondersitzung des bundestages
beantragt er will dann vor dem parlament
eine regierungserklärung abgeben
berlin ist natürlich im krisenmodus
gerade jetzt berät der
verteidigungsausschuss mit ministerin
lambrecht anwesend ist auch
oppositionsführer märz thomas reichert
in berlin was hören sie werden im rahmen
von nato aktivitäten auch möglichkeiten
eines bundeswehreinsatzes diskutiert die
bundeswehr ist schon sehr aktiv in
sachen nato
erlangen litauern stellt sie im rahmen
dieser battle group liegt das größte
kontingent das sind die soldaten im
februar noch einmal aufgestockt werden
350 weitere soldatinnen und soldaten so
dorthin verlegt worden
sie ist außerdem aktiv die luft werfe an
der südostflanke in rumänien und
bulgarien
da soll wahrscheinlich anfang nächster
woche sollen weitere eurofighter dorthin
verlegt werden um ein sogenanntes epo
leasing weiter zu verstärken also ein
luftraumüberwachung über dem schwarzen
meer da ist die krim ganz in der nähe
aber tatsache ist auch dass die
bundeswehr letztlich nicht so viel
anzubieten hat der heeresinspekteur
heute im grunde einen offenbarungseid
geleistet und gesagt dass er quasi blank
da steht mit weiteren leistungen des des
heeres zeigt sich einfach dass die
bundeswehr ausgerichtet ist auf
auslandseinsätze in afghanistan oder in
mali dass sie aber für ein bündnis
verlieh er sich nun jetzt darstellt mit
der invasion russlands in der ukraine
nicht gut vorbereitet ist und dass es
der grundlegende reform bedarf viel
besser vorbereitet so scheint es ist die
bundeswehr mit deutschland auf
sanktionen die jetzt kommen sollen und
die wahrscheinlich heute abend dann in
brüssel verkündet werden da genauer
hinschauen herzlichen dank auch nach
berlin thomas reichert bei der nato will
man zusätzliche maßnahmen für eine
stärkere abschreckung ergreifen mehr als
100 kampfflugzeuge seien in höchste
alarmbereitschaft versetzt worden sagte
generalsekretär stoltenberg in brüssel
und auch die europäische union hat einen
sondergipfel der staats- und
regierungschefs für den abend angesetzt
aber natürlich auch bereits reagiert
es dauert am morgen nicht lang bis in
brüssel die ersten eu spitzen vor die
kameras treten die
kommissionspräsidentin und der
außenbeauftragte verurteilen russlands
angriff als barbarischen akt dieser e on
the darkest hour das ist eine der
dunkelsten stunden in europa seit dem
ende des zweiten weltkriegs eine große
atommacht hat einen nachbarstaat
angegriffen und droht allen anderen
staaten die ihm zu hilfe kommen könnten
mit vergeltungsmaßnahmen
recht geben bereits als reaktion auf
moskaus anerkennung der separatisten
gebiete hatte die die am dienstag die
außenminister erste sanktionen
beschlossen gegen russische politiker
jetzt kündigt ursula von der leyen die
nächste stufe an
wir zielen auf strategisch wichtige
bereiche der russischen wirtschaft indem
wir den zugang zu technologien und
märkten blockieren die für russland
extrem wichtig sind
schon am abend werden die eu staats und
regierungschefs in brüssel erwartet ein
sondergipfel um diese sanktionen zu
beschließen
derweil aktiviert die nato ihren
verteidigungs plan für osteuropa
diese sitzen das ist eine
vorsichtsmaßnahme um die
nato-mitgliedstaaten in dieser krise zu
schützen
das ermöglicht uns weitere truppen und
material zu verlegen einschließlich der
nato eingreiftruppe dorthin wo sie
gebraucht wird
ein eingreifen der nato in der ukraine
aber schloss der generalsekretär erneut
aus die ukraine ist nicht mitglied der
nato
unmittelbar nach putins kriegs
ankündigung vor bald zehn stunden hatte
auch us-präsident beiden reagiert er
verurteilte den zitat ungerechtfertigten
angriff russlands auf die ukraine in
einem schriftlichen statement
bezeichnete auch er den angriff als
eklatanten bruch des völkerrechts biden
kündigte an später weitere maßnahmen
bekannt zu geben frage an elmar theveßen
in washington ja was gibt es jetzt ganz
aktuell an neuigkeiten aus der
us-regierung
ich habe meinen beiden bereitet sich auf
die telefonkonferenz vor die in knapp
einer stunde stattfinden wird mit den
anführern der g7 und er will natürlich
die amerikanischen erkenntnisse in die
runde mit einbringen über das was in der
ukraine gerade passiert und das macht
den pentagon die
verteidigungsministerium große sorge man
hat in der vergangenen nacht hier
gesehen dass offenbar große
panzerverbände über einen grenzübergang
im dreiländereck zwischen belarus
russland und ukraine über die grenze
gefahren sind auf eine straße die
geradewegs nach kiel führt und es gibt
jetzt erste meldungen dass etwa 20
kilometer vor kiew heftige gefechte im
gange sind und das nährt den verdacht
dem pentagon dass tatsächlich wladimir
putin ist darauf absieht kiew zu
besetzen die regierung möglicherweise
abzulösen und dafür zu sorgen dass es
keine befehlshaber mehr gibt den kiew
die daneben der armee im osten des
landes in irgendeiner weise befehle
erteilen oder die einsätze koordinieren
können das macht große sorgen darüber
wird der präsident gleich mit den g7
sprechen und dann natürlich auch über
die sanktionen die man verhängen will
vielen dank aber für den moment wir
werden das alles weiter beobachten und
berichten ganz aktuell dankeschön
schauen wir zum ende der sendung noch
einmal nach berlin dort haben einige
hundert menschen am brandenburger tor
gegen den einmarsch russlands in die
ukraine demonstriert unter ihnen sind
viele ukrainerinnen und ukraine auch am
nachmittag und abend sind weitere
proteste und
solidaritätskundgebungen angekündigt
unter anderem auch vor dem kanzleramt
und hier soll jetzt ein kurzer blick auf
die wetteraussichten nicht fehlen von
nordwesten her gibt es regen schnee und
graupelschauer örtlich gewitter und
kräftigen wind höchstwerte bei 3 bis 10
grad so viel für den moment auf zdf
heute aktualisieren wir alle weiteren
ereignisse permanent hier im programm
gibt es in allen nachrichtensendungen
kompakten zusammenfassungen die nächste
um 15 uhr
[Musik]
wind sind wenn doch ein ausnahme
künstler zwischen genie und wahnsinn
ein leben voller tragödien damen und
unglaublichen werken
lang verkannt ist er heute einer der
berühmtesten maler der welt
terrex sind